Markov of Carlo Manor are bringing back
special guest cards so here's everything
you need to know about them including
what are the odds are to open them and
which ones you should be looking for
let's jump into it in both play and
Collective boosters there is a small
chance that the common slot will be
replaced by a special guest card or a
card from the list special guest cards
are reprints from Magic's past with
brand new artwork often reflecting the
themes from the set they are a special
guest of whereas cards from the list are
just simply reprints from a pool of 40
cards that also change with each set
that simply have a Plains Walker symbol
in the bottom left corner for both these
cards are only playable in the formats
they're currently legal in but if you do
happen to open one during a limited
event like pre-release or draft they
will be legal for that event now what
are the actual odds of opening these
cards well in the new play boosters a
card from the list can replace a common
10.9% of the time whereas a special
guest card replaces it
1.56% of the time and in these packs the
special guest cards and the list cards
will always be nonfoil to get your hands
on a foil special guest card you can
only find them in collector boosters and
they appear in the traditional foil
booster fun rare or Mythic slot however
they only appear through 3% of the time
so this means if you buy a booster box
of play boosters which come with 36
packs on average there's only
0.56 special guest cards per box so for
every two boxes you open you're only
likely to see one special guest card and
if you buy a collector box which comes
with 12 boosters on average you'll
likely see
0.36 foil special guest cards basically
only one in every three boxes so there
are the odds now let's rank the 10 cards
you can open these ranks are done with
commander in mind but I'll mention their
relevance for other formats too starting
with the worst one of the bunch in the
number 10 slot we have tragic slip a one
Mana black instant that gives a creature
minus one minus one or if a creature
died this turn it gets -3 -3 instead
tragic slip pales in comparisons to
removal like path to Exile and swords to
plow shares and this card sees
practically no play in any of the major
formats it's going to be a real bummer
to hit your 1% chance special guest card
and to see this card staring back in the
ninth spot we have crashing foot falls a
card you can suspend for for a single
green Mana to eventually get two 44
Rhino tokens with trample now this card
is the Cornerstone of one of the best
best modern decks to date however it
sees absolutely no Commander play unlike
tragic slip at least if you open this
card and you don't play Modern you
should have no issues trading it away in
the eighth spot we have victimize a
three Mana black sorcery that lets you
reanimate two creatures with the
additional cost of sacrificing another
Creature if the spell resolves three
Mana to reanimate two creatures is
excellent value and the cost of
sacrificing another creature future is a
pretty easy price to pay for any deck in
Black while it still sucks that this is
simply an uncommon the artwork is
amazing and it's great in
Commander coming in at number seven we
have a personal favorite card of mine
ghostly prison a three Mana white
enchantment that makes it so creatures
can't attack you unless their controller
pays two Mana for each creature
attacking you we have here another card
that sees lots of play across Commander
both in enchantment decks control decks
and pillow for decks again this is just
another uncommon but at least it slots
into a good number of
decks at number six we have drown in the
lock a blue black two Mana instant that
either counters a spell with Mana value
less than or equal to the number of
cards in its controller's graveyard or
destroys a creature with Mana value less
than or equal to the number of cards in
its controller's graveyard while it does
see some Fringe play across Pioneer and
mil Commander is where this card
shines the flexibility of being able to
counter a spell or destroy a threat all
for Just Two Mana is not to be
underrated and I would not be
disappointed opening up one of these in
the number five spot we have tyus
tracker a green three minor 32 that
generates a clue on landfall and gets a
plus one plus one counter whenever you
sacrifice a clue while not the
PowerHouse it used to be tyus tracker is
an excellent card that easily slots into
token or landfall decks running green
and of course with Carlo Mana being
released the clue theme is back in full
swing and is a musthave there coming in
at number four there's fabricate the
older blue brother to idyllic chor
fabricate is a three Manor blue sorcery
that searches your library for an
artifact card and puts it into your hand
fabricate is an absolute staple for any
artifact deck running blue
as there are many powerful artifacts it
can search up while not as powerful as
vintage staple Tinker fabricate still
shows up in nearly every artifact
commander deck all righty top three time
and we have gamble to kick us off one of
if not the best chor in red gamble is a
one Mana sorcery that lets you search
your library for any card and put it
into your hand you then discard a card
at random gamble is a musthave card for
any red deck that needs to find a key
card whether that's something like mxus
Goblin Grande in your Goblin Kindred
deck or the combo piece you need in your
Drago the shipwrecker deck and while the
drawback of the card could be disastrous
you simply just need to know when to
hold them know when to fold them know
when to walk away and know when to run
at number two we have show and tell an
extremely powerful three Manor blue
sorcery where each player may put an
artifact creature enchantment or land
from their hand onto the battlefield
this card is so powerful it is one of
the two namesake cards from the Legacy
deck sneak and show which aims to cast
the spell on turn one and put either an
omniscience or Grizzle brand into play
while this card is a bit more risky to
play in Commander the player casting the
spell is usually the one to get the most
benefit from it as their deck is
generally built around this sort of play
and Fin finally the best card from this
set special guest cards is easily field
of the Dead this unassuming colorless
tap land creates a 2 two zombie for
every time you play a land when you
control seven or more lands with
different names controlling seven
differently named lands is certainly not
a hard task considering all the
non-basic lands nearly every commander
deck plays obviously this card is an
absolute Powerhouse in Decks that look
to play multiple land per turn and it
even gets more out of hand when you use
something like thesbian stage or vua to
copy it so there's all the special guest
cards and the odds of opening them which
ones are your favorite as always be sure
to like the video if you learn something
and subscribe if you run more than five
lands in your commander deck thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one